[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Tim legler ESPN NBA
analyst one of the great Shooters in the
history of the NBA all right legs who
was more deserving of being thrown from
their game Draymond was embiid just got
a technical
you're saying I only get one choice yeah
is that what we're doing here okay if I
have one choice I'm gonna go Draymond
but I think they both should have been
ejected now look I want to be I want to
be clear about something if it was
solely up to me
neither one of those guys is probably
getting ejected okay and I got some
reasons for that one is the fans pay
enough of a price during the regular
season that the number of games that
these guys don't play with load
management the number of you know how
much longer they take to come back from
injuries than they used to now you're
also going to punish fans that want to
watch playoff games by kicking guys out
for stuff that really didn't hurt
anybody I think sabonis sold that pretty
well I think Claxton sold it pretty well
the way he collapsed to the ground so it
was up to me solely neither guys getting
ejected but if you're gonna throw out
Draymond Green for retaliating when he
was provoked you've got to eject your
LMP for the same exact reason he was
provoked he intentionally tried to kick
him in the groin it just so happens he
missed the Target to me intent should go
behind it if that's the the basis for
the ejection Dan they both should have
been ejected explain to me how James
Harden is thrown out I can't because
that's one of the strangest ejections
I've ever seen
um in the 10 years I've played 20 plus
at ESPN I don't know that I've seen a
worse ejection James Harden right I mean
in any referee should know this looking
at the review if you're a basketball
player you've got the ball and you've
got a guy crowding you to the extent
that he was being crowded all Air space
is taken away there's already contact
before James Harden has even initiated
his move right the ball's going to be in
his right hand well your left hand just
the momentum of your left hand is going
to go forward and it's going to go out
to fend off the defender
you then have to make the determination
to look in that if you're Tony Brothers
you're looking at that film you have to
say did he intentionally punch him in
the groin and that's the determination
they made and I just don't know how you
conclude that when to me it was so
innocuous the motion with his left hand
was so short and abbreviated and he was
just trying to get some momentum and
fend him off to take that first dribble
it's an obvious basketball play so I was
shocked by it but look if you go look at
the tape
at most you say Okay offensive foul and
then if you really want to get extreme
let's give them a flagrant one because
the area of the body that he struck
there's no way you could toss a player
from a game particularly a superstar
from a game over something that to me
was completely unintentional I would
have given at worst harden a foul
offensive foul I would have called Royce
O'Neill for flopping
man listen this is a whole other subject
Dan do you remember a number of years
ago they they addressed this because it
had gotten out of out of control
right Rule and they had it at a point
where it was in the rule book that if
you flopped a certain number of times
you build up sort of like a point system
like we have in flagrance you could be
suspended for a game
obviously that just went away because
I've never seen
um an era in this league in which every
trip
virtually every trip someone is on the
ground trying to trick an efficient
so I I would I do want to give the
officials a little bit of leeway here
and say I I can't imagine how hard your
job is because you can't see it all
right some of it you catch out of your
peripheral and when you see a guy snap
his head back and shoulders go back and
fly on the ground these are big strong
professional athletes you know your
inclination as an official is like I
better call something something must
have happened it's so frequent now that
it's it's become a total Sideshow to the
actual action it's an art form these
guys should all have strict Screen
Actors Guild cards they're they're
perfecting trying to trick officials
into getting a call what happened to the
old days where I'm just gonna guard you
I'm going to stay on my feet I'm going
to guard you the best I can I'm going to
contest the shot at the end and if you
score on me I'm gonna do the same thing
the next time that that mentality is
gone it's let me see if I can get
something here let me see if I can
somehow you know Force an offensive foul
Force the official to go looking at a
review
um it's amazing to me the way that these
guys flail about the court uh with very
little contact to precipitate it Tim
legler wants you to get off his lawn
ESPN NBA analyst uh Kawhi didn't play I
I've been fascinated this past week
maybe 10 days uh with Kawhi Leonard and
how history is going to remember him and
and we're calling him rare Jordan
because when he plays he's Jordan like
but it's rare when he plays and it's a
it's a treat when he does but then he
doesn't play last night when it's all
said and done are we lumping him in is
he with Kevin Durant is he with Steph
Curry is he you know the new wave that's
you know going into the top 15 or 20
players of all time
yeah there's two ways of looking at the
answer that question I'm going to say no
the short answer is no he won't be and
it's because of what you just mentioned
I thought the same thing when I saw him
in the first game go against Kevin
Durant and miraculously I think it's the
first time they played against each
other since he got to the Clippers four
years ago
um when I saw him go up against Kevin
Durant I was so much anticipating that
matchup and look at him play so
spectacularly in that game I thought the
same thing man what have we been robbed
of by not watching that more often you
know over the last you know five years
um but as a result of that I don't think
he will be lumped in there because I
think when you look at Players Dan
historically there's two ways to look at
it when you want to rank them rank them
according to their talent and then you
have to also rank them according to
their career and for me that means being
out there being available playing a lot
of games you're missing the number of
post Seasons that he has missed
um so the talent is undeniable I think
Kawhi Leonard belongs in that category
with those guys but when you start
talking about waxing poetic about their
careers he's not going to be put into
that same category as the guys you just
mentioned the over under for LeBron
points against the Grizzlies game three
is 28 and a half
now we've been debating if he should
respond to Dylan Brooks Brooks saying
he's too old I don't respect you unless
you put 40 uh on me
what do you think LeBron should do in
game three against the Grizzlies in
Dylan Brooks
you know the great thing about LeBron
James is he can go for 35 or 40 and have
nothing to do with Dylan Brooks it just
happens organically by what the game
requires and his greatness so I think
he's going to dominate the game that
doesn't necessarily mean you go for a
huge scoring number he's going to do
what it takes to control the game
facilitate make guys better take
advantage of scoring opportunities what
would Kobe do
different mentality see so Kobe Kobe
didn't have the responsibility on his
plate to make sure everybody else was
cool on his team Kobe didn't have to
think that way now he still did it
because he was a great player he'd make
plays but he was a raw attacker that's
what Kobe was going to do that's what
Michael Jordan was as a player LeBron
has a different set of responsibilities
nightly and he's also got Anthony Davis
he's looking at you know every other
night looking at that barometer like
where's his energy level tonight maybe I
have to do a little extra as a scorer if
Anthony Davis is rolling early I don't
have to do as much as a scorer so he
reads the situation and he takes
advantage of scoring opportunities when
they're there it just Savage he's so
great that could mean a 35-40 point game
that has nothing to do with Dylan Brooks
you know getting his thermometer up him
I said no you're LeBron you have nothing
to prove and and don't even acknowledge
Dylan Brooks that's what he wants you're
going to drive him crazy by not
acknowledging him and Dylan Brooks he's
a Draymond wannabe you know he he you
know he's part of the headlines he's
getting attention he wants all those
things last thing you want to do is
acknowledging him
yeah I think even a better comparison
for me I said a couple days ago he's
more like the modern day version of
Lance Stevenson yeah right blowing in
LeBron's ear and like all the stuff that
that he was doing the difference is that
Dylan Brooks is is a more physical and
more capable and better Defender so like
LeBron has to he has to come ready to
play against a guy like Dylan Brooks
defensively Lance Stephenson it was more
literally like just a sideshow clown act
trying to get him to react at all so I
could say I won like kind of like Dylan
Brooks did the other night clapping when
LeBron finally acknowledged him by
staring at him Dylan books clapping in
his face it's it's it's literally like
you know a child trying to desperately
get that attention that they seek and
that's what Dylan Brooks is pretty good
at and so I agree he shouldn't
acknowledge Him don't stare him down
don't talk to him early in the game just
go be yourself and uh make sure that
when the game's over we're saying that
LeBron James is the best player on the
floor Golden State blowing Out
Sacramento I don't think anybody was
really surprised there but I'm wondering
about this when you play with the
teammate that you're constantly
answering for I get what point does
Golden State and staff and Clay Steve
Kerr like we gotta answer for Draymond
again draymond's not the player he once
was
but
they're still answering for him
how I mean is there conversation inside
that locker room that does anybody say
to Draymond hey come on
you know you can't be this you can't do
this does Steve Kerr take a role in any
of this stuff
I don't think those conversations really
are had maybe with Bob Meyer maybe the
front office but I really think that he
they believe he's such a volatile person
that they kind of don't want to
acknowledge it directly to him and they
say all the right things publicly about
having his back and supporting him and
we wouldn't have won these championships
without him so we're going to be there
and have his back
I'm sorry you can't tell me at some
level when Steph Curry goes home and
he's sitting down for dinner with his
family or Clay Thompson or Steve Kerr
goes home that they're not like oh my
gosh like I can't believe like I'm
dealing with this again like the stuff
that he finds himself in the midst of it
whether you want to say that's his fault
or not is what sabonis did to him you
know he didn't have that emotional break
that you need in certain moments man put
the brakes on and what he should have
done and we just talked about this the
flailing the flopping the guy's acting
How about if your dream on when he's got
a hold of your leg just go down yeah and
even if you like you wanna you wanna
cause some damage to sabonis while also
getting a foul on some bonus fall autumn
that's the best way to get back at it
because then they're going to say well
wait a second maybe this is a flagrant
foul against so bonus for grabbing his
leg and then twisting him to the ground
Draymond didn't have the wherewithal to
think about that in a moment instead
it's I'm gonna get back at this guy yeah
my foot free and it's absolutely
avoidable what he did with it next he
could have stepped to the side he did
not have to stomp on his chest so to
answer your question I think to his face
no and they say all the right things
publicly when they're privately with
their own thoughts or their own
conversations it has to be unbelievably
frustrating well he punched his own
teammate in practice legs so he can't
even control himself in an environment
where he it's Team friendly
I mean he's not going to be able to go
oh you know what let me act this way
he's bought into a WWE role and
it can be entertaining but man it can be
exhausting
it is you know it's a shame because it
really does detract from from what he is
as a player which is a guy that really
helps you win I mean he is to me as
great as he is defensively I think he's
more important to them offensively
because he is the guy that makes every
read he makes all the anticipatory
passes he reads all of that that that
action with the screening on the wings
and the back cuts the dribble handoffs
it's all reads on his part you have to
have an incredibly high IQ to do that
their offense flows when he's on the
floor defensively yeah he's obviously
very important I think offensive even
more important and instead we find
ourselves so often talking about these
things and negatively affecting his team
when he's had so much of an impact on
winning his entire career it's uh this
time of the year that we bring up that
you only played in three playoff games
and that was against Pete Michael Jordan
1997. Yeah well yeah and unfortunately
like I you know I I have a reminder all
the time time that my whole career was
the 90s and he won six rings he didn't
really and he didn't want to go hit
curveballs for a couple of years he
probably has eight rings I'm guessing
which basically takes up the entire
decade of my career
do you think if Jordan was still with
the bulls then go play baseball for
whatever reason
does do they do they win eight in a row
I think they do and you know here's the
thing you can't answer is you know when
he left he was clearly fried mentally so
the you know question is well okay he
doesn't play baseball but he just
continues to play in that state of mind
you know uh maybe not but that team was
certainly good enough and I have a
feeling once you know that warm weather
started to hit around April 15th no
matter what his regular season was like
or what he felt like mentally the
competitiveness comes out again and I
think that team probably does win eight
straight instead you know Hakeem uh
should have eternal thanks that he
decided to go do that uh for a couple
years so they could get a couple in
Houston great to talk to you again legs
thanks for making time for us
ESPN NBA analyst and uh won the
three-point shooting contest
played in three players he's the Mike
Trout of
ESPN analysts wow
what do you what history playoff games